trans-dimensional light bright chats an
epic d and d slash basketball montage
the scariest bad guy yet stranger things
is back and bigger than ever but with so
many plot lines to untangle you may need
some help wrapping your head around it
all keep watching for a handy guide to
the ending of season 4 part 1.
it seemed like stranger things season 4
was going to be split between the
midwest and the west coast with a
california contingent set to have their
own spring break storyline but things go
downhill out west and fast there's
tension between mike will and l and
that's even before l bashes the local
mean girl angela in the face with a
skate the lenora hills police arrive at
the buyer's residence to book l for
assault but the military and the hawkins
lab are looking forward too dr owen's
team assigns a security detail to the
buyer's house breaks al out and
convinces her to go to his underground
lab where he may be able to restore her
powers she panics when she sees dr
brenner again and has to be sedated but
her telekinetic abilities start to come
back and she decides to participate
willingly in the nina project but
government forces led by lieutenant
colonel sullivan are hot on their trail
after a harrowing shootout mike will and
jonathan escape with a wounded guard in
argyle's van the guard dies but not
before giving mike a pen that contains a
secret phone number that isn't quite
what it appears we're not calling a
phone
we're calling a computer
mike guides him to salt lake city where
dustin's hacker girlfriend lives susie
who thinks they're trying to win dusty a
video game console informs them her pc
has been confiscated as punishment for
changing dustin's latin grade however
her many siblings create a distraction
that allows them to sneak into her dad's
office and trace the ip address to
coordinates in nevada when last we see
them they're ready to hit the road again
and rescue l with a print out to the
location at hand
jason carver sure thinks he's the good
guy but it's obvious to every stranger
things fan from his first appearance at
the pep rally that he's actually one of
the season's many antagonists
we know that his girlfriend chrissy was
seeing the guidance counselor presumably
because her mom contributed to her body
image issues but the way she interacts
with eddie suggests her relationship
with jason may not have been everything
the couple presented it as just about
everybody suspects eddie is responsible
for chrissy's murder but because her
death is so unusual with no signs of
physical contact there are lingering
questions the police theorize that
chrissy was at eddie's trailer to buy
drugs which jason refuses to believe
despite it being totally true so
how does this work exactly he doesn't
like the way the cops are handling the
case so he assembles his basketball
teammates including lucas and takes
matters into his own hands jason beats
it out of eddie's bandmate that dustin
might know something lucas helps his
friends evade the jocks but they catch
up to eddie at lovers lake jason and
teammate patrick swim after eddie as he
tries to escape in a boat that's when
vecna kills patrick in spectacular
fashion
rather than this convincing jason of
eddie's innocence the jock doubles down
jason interrupts a public forum with a
fiery speech that mirrors his episode 1
pep talk in which he insists that eddie
has made a deal with the devil and that
the hellfire club is a dangerous satanic
cult most of the townspeople join him to
hunt down eddie and the rest of the gang
to find the curfew they're still out
there with metaphorical pitchforks
raised at the end of part 1. the hawkins
gang is desperate to clear eddie's name
and defeat vecna before max becomes his
next victim they follow dustin's compass
which goes haywire around otherworldly
energy to lovers lake where patrick met
his end only hours before nancy recalls
that passageways between dimensions seem
to appear around kill sites the older
kids nancy robin steve and eddie take
the boat to see if this holds true for
vechna while the younger kids dust in
max and lucas stay on the shore steve
finds a gate to the bottom of the lake
but he gets ensnared by a vine and
pulled into the upside down he's
attacked by demobats before he's saved
by nancy robin and eddie who follow each
other through the ominous glowing terror
uh do you guys think these bats have
like rabies
what demo bats are guarding the water
gates so the crew retreats to upside
down skull rock then the upside down
wheeler house there they can hear the
other kids in the real house where
they're being held for questioning eddie
uses a chandelier to signal sos and
morse code then dustin and nancy
communicate via life right he reminds
them that if every attack creates a gate
there should be one in eddie's uncle's
trailer where chrissy died not to
mention one near where fred died which
may yet come into play steve nancy robin
and eddie jump onto the wheeler's bikes
and ride seven miles to the trailer park
where sure enough there's a big red gash
in the ceiling it provides an escape
route but it also establishes an
important fact that may be of even more
consequence in part two becna attacks
open gates
once they're in the upside down nancy
suggests they arm themselves with guns
she keeps in her bedroom unfortunately
when they arrive at the alternate
version of the wheeler house and rummage
through nancy's room the guns are
nowhere to be found nancy thinks she
knows why when she picks up an old diary
in a real bedroom on the surface the
diaries pages are filled up with entries
but in this dimension nancy's journaling
stops on november 6 1983 the day will
went missing back in the series premiere
we're in the past we don't yet
understand the extent to which nancy's
hypothesis is true her room is frozen in
time and it's possible that the whole
place works according to the same time
keeping system a more likely explanation
is that in the upside down time is
variable nancy's bedroom is probably
standing still at what's either her most
guilt-ridden moment barb's death or her
first contact with its otherworldly
creatures similarly the upside down
creel house which appears to be a vital
location perhaps even the dimension
center may well turn out to be stuck in
1959 the year in which the horrific
tragedy occurred there if time is
relative on the other side of these
gates and especially if it's tied to
individual experience that adds a
fascinating new component to stranger
things lore that could help explain
quite a bit about the show's mysterious
underworld the storyline that's most
disconnected from the rest of the show
at least so far is the plot involving
joyce and murray's attempt to spring
hopper from a russian prison joyce
receives a package from russia that
contains a doll she contacts murray who
instructs her to break it and she finds
a ransom note someone calling themselves
enzo wants them to bring 40 000 to
alaska in exchange for their friend it's
not a very realistic plan enzo real name
dimitri gives them 100 to 1 odds and it
goes disastrously wrong hopper breaks
his foot to slip off his cuffs and run
but is captured at the agreed upon
meeting place when their go-between yuri
double-crosses them for more money joyce
and murray managed to overtake yuri in
midair thanks to murray's black belt
level combat training but since they
don't know how to fly they crash land
the plane back at the prison murray
successfully impersonates yuri and gets
him inside where they see hopper dimitri
and about a dozen other captives in a
pit preparing for a fight a mechanized
reinforced door opens and out comes a
demogorgon it quickly dispatches most of
the prisoners but hopper manages to keep
it at bay with a makeshift spear torch
meanwhile murray tries threatening the
guards into opening the pit door but
they stay loyal to mother russia so
murray resorts to martial arts again
i gotta hand it to you commies you're
committed when it's all over hopper and
dimitri are on the other side of the
door from the demigorgon and hopper and
joyce get to reunite but at the moment
they're all still stranded in russia
one of the reveals that packs the most
punch in part one is max's realization
that her mind has been corrupted by
vecna early on we're led to believe that
her depressive mood visits to the
guidance counselor and breakup with
lucas have to do with the trauma she
suffered witnessing billy's brutal death
and the impact it had on her family her
abusive stepdad left but she and her
alcoholic mother are near destitute in
the trailer park max doesn't want the
counselor's help but she does want
information about chrissy when she can't
pry any details from miss kelly mac
steals her key and reads her files she
discovers that fred benson nancy's
deceased reporting partner was a patient
too and that all three of them have had
the same symptoms headaches nightmares
nosebleeds and visions max sees the
grandfather clock that appears the
victim's victim shortly before he takes
them and knows she only has about a day
left she has a full-blown encounter with
vegna at billy's grave before she's
brought back by the sound of her
favorite song running up that hill a
deal with god by kate bush as long as
she's got her walkman she's safe but
that's still a pretty precarious
position to be in
jumping ahead to the upside down rescue
plots nancy climbs through the gates
into eddie's trailer but is possessed by
vecna before she can make it home while
max saw a vision to billy nancy relives
barb's death and then ends up in the
upside down's deconstructed version of
the creel house where she witnesses
scenes from vechna's childhood steve is
left frantically trying to shake her
back to consciousness
season four begins with a flashback
sequence that implies an eight-year-old
11 used her powers to kill all the
children and most of the guards at the
hawkins lab on september 8 1979. what
actually happened in the highly
classified facility that night is the
central mystery of the first seven
episodes dr owens and dr brenner think
elle can restore her abilities by
reprocessing her memories in the neenah
machine when she's floated in water and
hooked up to its sensors elry lives a
series of confusing and sometimes
painful memories many of which she
suppressed until they begin to make
sense a creepy but compassionate lab
assistant named peter ballard begins to
confide in eleven especially when it
becomes clear that she's been subjected
to vicious bullying by the other
children sometimes
papa doesn't tell the truth after one of
their attacks leaves her with a
concussion balor tells her that dr
brenner intends to let them finish her
off next time as he fears she's too
powerful and difficult to control
she believes him as she witnessed the
staff beat him for what she assumes was
his kindness to her before he offers to
help her run and in return she
telekinetically removes a small device
from under his skin it's at this point
that l realizes ballard has powers too
earlier he said she reminded him of
number one l replied that papa told them
he didn't exist but ballard countered
that papa often lied after she tore out
his chip which may have been a tracker a
device to block his power or both he
tells al that he's like her and then he
shows her his tattoo it reads zero zero
one
l had suppressed the hawkins lab
massacre but her sessions in the nina
machine convince her she was a
cold-blooded killer she fears she
retaliated for their bullying as she
done with angela
when the full picture comes into focus
she learns the truth in a way elle is
somewhat responsible for the massacre
but only because she freed one through
her memories we see that one committed
to mass murder once his powers were
restored elle only caught him in the act
when she didn't stay hidden which leads
to their dramatic and extremely
expository final confrontation
peter ballard is actually the son of
victor creel the family moved to hawkins
because he was giving his parents
trouble and they thought a fresh start
might fix everything it didn't we see
the still disturbed young boy kill a
rabbit in the same manner that becknut
killed chrissy
the creoles were seeking the wisdom of a
doctor when their son fearing he'd be
institutionalized possessed and murdered
his mother and sister and framed his
father that doctor turned out to be
brenner who covered up once crimes and
took him back to his lab to study him
and make more individuals like him one
begins to twist eleven's limbs but she
summons all her strength and basically
dissolves him this opens what might be
the first gate to the upside down and
transforms one into vechna the incident
explains why vekna lurks around the
creel house but we still know very
little about the origins of his powers
it's also notable that elle's attack
opens the gate in the rainbow room which
strongly suggests her gifts and by
extension one's gifts came from the
upside down
stranger things has always made the most
of its retro setting aesthetically
speaking with period correct fashion and
music as well as details like food
packaging and movie posters season four
takes the historical and cultural
references to a whole new level as the
satanic panic that gripped the country
in the mid 80s factors directly into the
plot in the world of the show basketball
captain jason thinks the hellfire club
is a demonic cult murders are
ritualistic sacrifices he claims he's
heard about the phenomenon on the news
and he has a pretty easy time swaying
most of hawkins to his point of view
lucas's sister protests that hellfire is
just a club for nerds but jason and his
mob are on the side of hysteria and even
mike dustin and lucas's parents have
their doubts the storyline is completely
based in reality around the time the
series takes place america was
irrationally concerned with satanism
kids who like dungeons and dragons or
ozzy osbourne became scapegoats for
cultural shifts that made some people
uncomfortable there was even a 60 minute
special all about it in case the parents
were actually saw their child summon
dungeons and dragons demons into his
room before he killed himself anyone
who's actually played d knows how silly
that is but edgy teens weren't the
satanic panic's only victims anyone
could be suspected of corrupting or
abusing children including daycare
workers whose lives were ruined by
accusations since stranger things isn't
finished with its own moral hysteria
storyline things are probably going to
get worse for the hellfire club before
they get better
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
stranger things are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]